Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app, or on our website. It was a windy Sunday night on October 6, 1974, as two Queensland police officers drove along the forested roads to Yuccanavale Youth Camp. They were greeted by the camp's caretakers, who appeared flustered. For the past half hour, their remote and peaceful surroundings had been intermittently disturbed by a frightening noise. The officers listened. A few minutes later,
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集节目的说明。1974年10月6日，一个风雨交加的周日夜晚，两名昆士兰警官开车沿着森林公路前往尤卡纳维尔（Yuccanavale）青年营。他们受到了营地管理员的迎接，管理员看起来十分慌乱。在过去的半小时里，他们偏远而宁静的环境断断续续地被一种可怕的声音所干扰。警官们仔细聆听。几分钟后，
they heard it for themselves. Blood-curdling screams. For the first time in Officer Ian Hamilton's career, the hairs on the back of his neck stood up. He had never heard such a horrendous and terrifying sound. It didn't seem like the screams were coming from just one person, either. The difference in pitch indicated there were at least two women screaming for help. Like the caretakers, the officers couldn't determine what direction the screams were coming from. The Yuccanavale Youth Camp was situated on the uphill section of the Toowoomba Range, about halfway between the inland city of Toowoomba and the rural town of Withcott. This mountainous location, mixed with the blustery winds, meant the origin of the screams kept
他们亲耳听到了。那是令人毛骨悚然的尖叫声。在伊恩·汉密尔顿（Ian Hamilton）警官的职业生涯中，这是他第一次感到后颈发凉。他从未听过如此恐怖和骇人的声音。而且，尖叫声似乎并不只是来自一个人。音调的差异表明至少有两名女性在尖叫求救。和管理员一样，警官们无法确定尖叫声来自哪个方向。尤卡纳维尔青年营位于图文巴山脉（Toowoomba Range）的上坡路段，大约位于内陆城市图文巴和乡村小镇威斯科特（Withcott）之间。这个多山的地理位置，加上狂风，意味着尖叫声的来源不断
changing. One minute it sounded like they were coming from the top of the range, the next it sounded like they were coming from the east. After 40 frustrating minutes helplessly listening to the distorted screams echo around them, everything went quiet. The officers drove up and down the range on the lookout for anyone in trouble. Every now and then they stopped and got out to see if the screams had started up again, but they were met with silence. For 20-year-old Lorraine Wilson, nursing had been an obvious career choice. The youngest of four children in a close-knit family, she followed in the footsteps of her mother who had served as a nurse in Sydney during World War II. The Wilson family lived on a farm 64 kilometers outside of
变化。一会儿听起来像是来自山顶，一会儿又像是来自东方。在经历了40分钟无奈地听着扭曲的尖叫声在周围回荡的沮丧时刻后，一切归于平静。警官们开车在山脉上下巡逻，寻找任何陷入困境的人。他们不时停下车走出来，看看尖叫声是否再次响起，但迎接他们的只有寂静。对于20岁的洛林·威尔逊（Lorraine Wilson）来说，护理是一个显而易见的职业选择。作为家中四个孩子里最小的一个，她出生在一个关系紧密的家庭，追随了母亲的脚步，母亲曾在二战期间在悉尼担任护士。威尔逊一家住在距离
Dubbo, a small city in central New South Wales. They predominantly lived off the land, with the children helping their parents take care of the daily chores. It was a humble and enjoyable upbringing, which taught Lorraine the value of hard work. An avid animal lover, she especially loved taking care of the domestic pets, which included dogs, cats, chickens, lambs and birds. Lorraine's work ethic, combined with her compassionate nature, inspired her to pursue nursing after finishing high school. The last of her siblings to leave the nest, she moved to Sydney to begin her live-in training at St George Hospital. It was there that she met fellow trainee, 18-year-old Wendy Evans. Like Lorraine, Wendy shared the unique traits necessary to succeed as a nurse,
新南威尔士州中部小城市达博（Dubbo）64公里外的一个农场里。他们主要靠土地为生，孩子们帮助父母处理日常杂务。这是一种朴实而愉快的成长经历，教会了洛林勤劳的价值。作为一名狂热的动物爱好者，她特别喜欢照顾家里的宠物，包括狗、猫、鸡、羊和鸟。洛林的职业道德，加上她富有同情心的天性，激励她在高中毕业后从事护理工作。作为最后一个离家的孩子，她搬到悉尼，开始在圣乔治医院（St George Hospital）进行住院培训。正是在那里，她遇到了同为实习生的18岁温迪·埃文斯（Wendy Evans）。和洛林一样，温迪也具备了成为一名成功护士所需的独特品质，
strength, empathy and understanding. She too had grown up in a close-knit family and was one of four children. Wendy had a more urban upbringing in Sydney's inner west, but that didn't prevent her and Lorraine from becoming close friends. They excelled at their training, topping their classes in such subjects as neurology. By late August 1974, Lorraine and Wendy had completed their first year of studies. To celebrate, they embarked on an interstate bus tour together, visiting popular tourist destinations like Townsville, Mount Isa, Catherine, Darwin and Alice Springs. The trip ended in Dubbo. The two friends spent a few days on the Wilson's family farm before heading off in Lorraine's Volkswagen Beetle for the final leg of their journey, an 800-kilometre road trip to Brisbane.
力量、同理心和理解力。她也在一个关系紧密的家庭中长大，是四个孩子之一。温迪在悉尼内西区有着更城市化的成长背景，但这并没有阻止她和洛林成为亲密的朋友。她们在培训中表现优异，在神经学等学科中名列前茅。到1974年8月下旬，洛林和温迪完成了第一年的学业。为了庆祝，她们一起开始了跨州巴士之旅，参观了汤斯维尔（Townsville）、伊萨山（Mount Isa）、凯瑟琳（Catherine）、达尔文（Darwin）和爱丽丝泉（Alice Springs）等热门旅游目的地。旅程在达博结束。两位朋友在威尔逊家的农场待了几天，然后开着洛林的甲壳虫汽车开始了旅程的最后一段，一段前往布里斯班的800公里公路旅行。
Halfway there, the car broke down and had to be towed to a mechanic who calculated it would take at least a week to fix. This threw a major spanner in the works. The friends were on a tight budget and didn't have extra money for alternative transport. They were hesitant about hitchhiking, but after some deliberation, they decided to take the risk. It paid off. The man who picked them up was so friendly he even stopped to buy them burgers before dropping them at the home of Wendy's sister, Susan, who lived in the suburb of Camp Hill. Lorraine and Wendy spent six days exploring and shopping in Brisbane while catching up with Susan and her family. By Sunday, October 6, the pair were ready to head home to be back at work on Thursday.
在半路上，车子抛锚了，不得不被拖到一位机械师那里，他计算出至少需要一周时间才能修好。这给她们的计划带来了重大阻碍。朋友们预算紧张，没有多余的钱用于其他交通工具。她们对搭便车感到犹豫，但经过一番商量，她们决定冒险一试。这得到了回报。载她们的那个人非常友好，甚至停下来给她们买了汉堡，然后把她们送到温迪的姐姐苏珊（Susan）家，苏珊住在坎普山（Camp Hill）郊区。洛林和温迪在布里斯班花了六天时间探索和购物，同时与苏珊及其家人叙旧。到了10月6日星期日，两人准备回家，以便在周四回到工作岗位。
They were running out of money, but Lorraine's Volkswagen still wasn't ready to be picked up. They considered their options. Given the positive experience they'd had hitchhiking to Brisbane, they decided to hitch a ride back to the Wilson's farm in Dubbo. Susan urged them to reconsider. They were welcome to stay until Lorraine's car was ready, or she could lend them money for a train or bus ticket. Wendy considered her sister's offer, but Lorraine was confident that everything would be okay. The friends were sure their good luck would continue. Wendy reassured her sister, saying, I've got Lorraine to protect me. When the young women failed to arrive in Dubbo, Lorraine's mother, Betty, told herself that they
她们的钱快花光了，但洛林的甲壳虫汽车还没修好。她们考虑了各种选择。鉴于她们之前搭便车去布里斯班的积极经历，她们决定搭便车回达博的威尔逊农场。苏珊劝她们三思。她们可以留下来直到洛林的车修好，或者她可以借钱给她们买火车票或巴士票。温迪考虑了姐姐的提议，但洛林确信一切都会好起来的。朋友们确信她们的好运会持续下去。温迪安慰姐姐说：“我有洛林保护我。”当这两个年轻女子没能到达达博时，洛林的母亲贝蒂（Betty）告诉自己，她们
must have made last-minute plans. But she could feel in her bones that something was wrong. It was only after Lorraine and Wendy failed to appear for work on Thursday that the pair were realized as missing. A police investigator told her that she had been missing for a while. A police investigation was launched. Lorraine and Wendy hadn't told anyone what route they intended to take from Brisbane, or whether they intended to stop anywhere along the way. With no concrete information to use as a starting point, it was like searching for a needle in a near 900km long haystack. Lorraine's parents hit the road, retrieving the car from the road, the friends had taken on their journey up to Brisbane.
一定是临时改变了计划。但她内心深处感觉到有些不对劲。直到洛林和温迪周四没去上班，人们才意识到两人失踪了。一名警官告诉她，她已经失踪了一段时间。警方展开了调查。洛林和温迪没有告诉任何人她们打算从布里斯班走哪条路线，或者她们是否打算在途中停留。由于没有具体的起点信息，这就像在近900公里长的干草堆里寻找一根针。洛林的父母踏上了旅程，从路上找回了朋友们去布里斯班时开的那辆车。
They showed photos to everyone they crossed paths with, and spoke to the media along the way, doing everything in their power to bring publicity to Lorraine and Wendy's disappearance. Reported sightings of the young nurses came in from all over the country, but none could be verified. Reported sightings of the young nurses came in from all over the country, but none could be verified. Neither Lorraine or Wendy had touched their bank accounts since the day before they left Camp Hill. As time wore on, the possibility grew that they had met with foul play. Taking the mentality that no news is good news, the Wilson family remained hopeful that the young women would be found alive. The Evans family were less optimistic.
她们向遇到的每一个人展示照片，并沿途接受媒体采访，尽其所能宣传洛林和温迪的失踪。全国各地都有关于这两位年轻护士的目击报告，但都无法证实。全国各地都有关于这两位年轻护士的目击报告，但都无法证实。自离开坎普山的前一天起，洛林和温迪都没有动过她们的银行账户。随着时间的推移，她们遭遇不测的可能性越来越大。威尔逊一家抱着“没有消息就是好消息”的心态，仍然希望这两位年轻女子能活着被找到。埃文斯一家则没那么乐观。
By the time Wendy had been missing for four months, her sister Susan had given birth, meaning Wendy had become an aunt again. The fact she didn't reach out could only suggest that something terrible had happened. Wendy's mother Alice told reporters, I now feel the situation is hopeless for my daughter and just want to know where she lies dead. There is no doubt in my mind that the worst has happened. The investigation continued, but no promising leads emerged. By Friday, June 25, 1975, the two friends had been missing for almost 21 months. That day, an elderly couple went for a leisurely drive to Murphy's Creek,
到温迪失踪四个月时，她的姐姐苏珊已经生了孩子，这意味着温迪又多了一个侄子/女。她没有联系家人，这只能说明发生了可怕的事情。温迪的母亲爱丽丝（Alice）告诉记者：“我现在觉得我女儿的情况毫无希望，我只想知道她死在哪里。我毫不怀疑最坏的情况已经发生了。”调查仍在继续，但没有出现有希望的线索。到1975年6月25日星期五，这两位朋友已经失踪了近21个月。那天，一对老夫妇开车去墨菲溪（Murphy's Creek）悠闲地兜风，
a small historic settlement approximately 30 kilometres northeast of Toowoomba. The couple drove down Murphy's Creek Road, a rural thoroughfare surrounded by dense bushland and dry paddocks. About two and a half kilometres outside the township, they turned down an unsealed dirt road. After 900 metres, they parked their car near a split rail fence. It was an isolated area with residential homes few and far between. The closest farmhouse was about 800 metres away, making it an ideal spot for a private picnic. As they ate lunch in their car, a wallaby hopped past the couple's vehicle. They decided to get out and follow it.
这是一个距离图文巴东北约30公里的小型历史定居点。这对夫妇沿着墨菲溪路（Murphy's Creek Road）行驶，这是一条被茂密的灌木丛和干燥的围场环绕的乡村道路。在距离镇中心约2.5公里处，他们转入了一条未铺设的土路。行驶900米后，他们把车停在了一道分体式栅栏旁。这是一个偏僻的地方，住宅稀少。最近的农舍距离约800米，是私人野餐的理想场所。当他们在车里吃午饭时，一只小袋鼠从他们的车旁跳过。他们决定下车跟着它。
The pair scaled a barbed wire fence that framed a private property before walking into a wooded paddock. After heading through a cluster of trees, they came across a small clearing. It looked like some kind of rubbish dump. On the ground, all kinds of items were strewn about, clothing, cosmetics, bags and other personal belongings. The man bent down to get a better look at a discarded camera, when his companion noticed something on the ground nearby. A human skull. This wasn't just a rubbish dump. It was a burial site. The couple rushed back to their car and drove towards Toowoomba.
两人翻过了一道围住私人领地的铁丝网，走进了一个树木繁茂的围场。穿过一片树丛后，他们来到了一片小空地。看起来像是个垃圾场。地上散落着各种各样的物品，衣服、化妆品、包和其他个人物品。男人弯下腰想看清楚一个被丢弃的相机时，他的同伴注意到附近地上有什么东西。一个人类头骨。这不仅仅是一个垃圾场。这是一个埋尸地。这对夫妇匆忙回到车里，开车前往图文巴。
By chance, they passed a police car and stopped to inform the officer what they'd found. The officer followed the couple back to the clearing, where he identified two human skulls and other human bones. Amongst the personal belongings dumped throughout the site was a transistor radio. A name was engraved on the back. Lorraine Wilson. Within hours, the remote site was teeming with police. They uncovered the mostly intact skeletons belonging to Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans. Although wildlife had dispersed some of the bones, it was clear that the two bodies had initially been dumped side by side. Their killer had made no attempt to hide the bodies.
偶然间，他们经过一辆警车，停下来告诉警官他们的发现。警官跟着这对夫妇回到空地，在那里他确认了两个人类头骨和其他人类骨骼。在散落在现场的个人物品中，有一个晶体管收音机。背面刻着一个名字：洛林·威尔逊。几小时内，这个偏远的地方挤满了警察。他们发现了属于洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯的几乎完整的骨架。虽然野生动物已经分散了一些骨头，但很明显，这两具尸体最初是被并排丢弃的。凶手没有试图隐藏尸体。
They likely deemed it unnecessary, given the remote spot was obstructed by trees and at the rear of a 2000 acre plot of farmland. Both women had sustained fatal head injuries, possibly inflicted by a large piece of timber found nearby. Lorraine had been struck on the back of the head between one and three times, whereas Wendy had endured multiple extensive injuries. A forensic examiner determined that Wendy's face had been, quote, bashed to a pulp. Remnants of a thin, looped synthetic cord indicated both women had been hogtired, but the state of the remains meant it couldn't be ascertained whether either of them had been
他们可能认为没必要，因为这个偏远的地方被树木遮挡，位于一个2000英亩农场的后方。两名女性都遭受了致命的头部伤害，可能是被附近发现的一大块木头造成的。洛林后脑勺被击中了一到三次，而温迪则遭受了多处严重的伤害。法医检查确定温迪的脸被“打成了肉泥”。细环合成绳的残留物表明两名女性都被捆绑过，但遗骸的状态意味着无法确定她们中是否有人曾
sexually assaulted. Their jeans and underwear were still in place, their bra straps were fastened, and the cord had been tied over their jeans. Had they been raped, it likely happened sometime before they were killed. All up, a total of 90 personal items belonging to Lorraine and Wendy were found at the bush side, everything they'd been carrying on their journey from Brisbane. Only a few items were missing, both of their wallets and two bank books. However, it didn't necessarily seem that the killer was motivated by robbery. Lorraine and Wendy still had their jewellery, including a pendant necklace,
遭受性侵犯。她们的牛仔裤和内衣还在原位，胸罩带扣着，绳子系在牛仔裤外面。如果她们被强奸了，那很可能发生在她们被杀之前。总共在灌木丛现场发现了属于洛林和温迪的90件个人物品，包括她们在从布里斯班出发的旅途中携带的所有东西。只有几件物品不见了，她们的两个钱包和两本银行存折。然而，凶手似乎并不一定是为了抢劫。洛林和温迪仍然戴着她们的首饰，包括一条吊坠项链、
a gold bracelet, and Lorraine's prized antique ring. Using a metal detector, an army officer scanned a dry mound of dirt nearby. They located a men's silver signet ring with a large green stone. This was the only item that couldn't be attributed to either Lorraine or Wendy. While it was possible that the killer had accidentally lost the ring, another scenario had to be considered. What if the killer, or someone who knew of the crime, had intentionally left it behind as a clue? The crime scene was around a two-hour drive west of Camp Hill, where Lorraine and Wendy were last seen alive.
一条金手链和洛林珍贵的古董戒指。一名军官用金属探测器扫描了附近一个干燥的土堆。他们发现了一枚带有大块绿色宝石的男士银质图章戒指。这是唯一一件无法归属于洛林或温迪的物品。虽然凶手可能不小心丢失了戒指，但必须考虑另一种情况。如果凶手，或者知道这起罪行的人，故意把它留作线索呢？犯罪现场距离洛林和温迪最后一次活着被看到的坎普山大约有两小时的车程。
Investigators deemed it unlikely that the pair had been killed elsewhere before being dumped at Murphy's Creek. It would have been too difficult to cut their bodies over the barbed wire fence and dense bush to the burial site. It made much more sense that Lorraine and Wendy had met their fate in this isolated location, where no one would hear them scream, except someone did. When police officer Ian Hummelton heard about the discovery of the remains, he immediately thought back to the night of Sunday, October 6, 1974. He and his partner had been unable to locate the source of two women screaming in the Toowoomba Ranges region.
调查人员认为，两人在被丢弃到墨菲溪之前在别处被杀的可能性不大。要把她们的尸体抬过铁丝网和茂密的灌木丛运到埋尸地太困难了。更有可能的是，洛林和温迪是在这个偏僻的地方遭遇不幸的，那里没有人会听到她们的尖叫，除了有人听到了。当伊恩·汉密尔顿警官听说发现遗骸的消息时，他立刻回想起1974年10月6日星期日的那个晚上。他和他的搭档当时无法找到图文巴山脉地区两名女性尖叫声的来源。
He checked his records and confirmed that the incident had happened on the same day that Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans went missing. Based on this information, investigators concluded the screams had come from the two nurses and that they had likely been killed the same day they left Brisbane. Lorraine and Wendy had briefly mentioned wanting to go sunbathing on the Gold Coast. This became a significant detail. In July 1972, 18-year-old Robin Hoinville-Bartram and her friend 19-year-old Anita Cunningham had hitchhiked to Queensland and were last seen in the Gold Coast suburb of Coulangatta. Four months later, Robin's body was found under a bridge in the rural town of Charter's Towers. She had been shot twice with a rifle.
他查阅了记录，确认该事件发生的日期与洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯失踪的日期相同。根据这些信息，调查人员得出结论，尖叫声来自这两名护士，她们很可能在离开布里斯班的当天就被杀了。洛林和温迪曾简短地提到想去黄金海岸晒太阳。这成了一个重要的细节。1972年7月，18岁的罗宾·霍因维尔-巴特拉姆（Robin Hoinville-Bartram）和她19岁的朋友安妮塔·坎宁安（Anita Cunningham）搭便车前往昆士兰，最后一次被看到是在黄金海岸的库伦加塔（Coulangatta）郊区。四个月后，罗宾的尸体在乡村小镇查特斯塔（Charter's Towers）的一座桥下被发现。她被步枪击中了两枪。
Anita's body was never found, but police were certain she'd met the same fate. Then on October 6, 1973, one year to the day before Lorraine and Wendy went missing, best friends Michelle Riley and Gabrielle Jenke got out of a taxi in Brisbane's CBD. The 16- and 19-year-old planned to hitchhike to the Gold Coast. A week later, Gabrielle's decomposing body was found at the bottom of an embankment on the side of the Pacific Highway. 11 days on and 25 kilometres away, Michelle's body was found in bushes off the Mount Tambourine Highway. Both teens had been sexually assaulted and bludgeoned to death in what police described as a
安妮塔的尸体从未被找到，但警方确信她遭遇了同样的命运。然后，在1973年10月6日，即洛林和温迪失踪整整一年前，最好的朋友米歇尔·莱利（Michelle Riley）和加布里埃尔·詹克（Gabrielle Jenke）在布里斯班市中心下了一辆出租车。这两名16岁和19岁的女孩计划搭便车去黄金海岸。一周后，加布里埃尔腐烂的尸体在太平洋高速公路旁的路堤底部被发现。11天后，在25公里外，米歇尔的尸体在坦伯林山（Mount Tambourine）高速公路旁的灌木丛中被发现。两名少女都遭到了性侵犯并被殴打致死，警方称这是一起
frenzied attack. On May 5, a month and a half before Lorraine and Wendy's bodies were found, Gold Coast teenager Margaret Roseworn attempted to hitchhike from surface paradise to a party in nearby Burley Heads. 16 days later, her body was discovered amongst overgrown grass on a vacant block in West Burley. She had been beaten so ferociously that dental records were needed to make a positive identification. It appeared as though a struggle had taken place on a nearby road, leading investigators to believe Margaret had tried to flee from someone's car. Including Lorraine and Wendy, all seven women were of a similar age group and had gone missing while hitchhiking in the Brisbane Gold Coast areas. Five of them were bludgeoned to death
疯狂的袭击。5月5日，在洛林和温迪的尸体被发现前一个半月，黄金海岸的少女玛格丽特·罗斯沃恩（Margaret Roseworn）试图从冲浪者天堂搭便车去附近的伯利角（Burley Heads）参加聚会。16天后，她的尸体在西伯利一个空地上的杂草中被发现。她被殴打得如此惨烈，以至于需要牙科记录才能进行正面确认。看起来附近的一条路上发生过挣扎，这让调查人员认为玛格丽特曾试图从某人的车里逃跑。包括洛林和温迪在内，所有七名女性年龄相仿，都是在布里斯班-黄金海岸地区搭便车时失踪的。其中五人被殴打致死
and likely sexually assaulted, their bodies disposed of relatively out in the open. The similarities seemed too strong to be purely coincidental. Was it possible that all seven of the young women had fallen victim to the same cold-blooded killer, who the public had dubbed, the Gold Coast Hitchhiker Murderer? A $100,000 reward for information pertaining to the Wilson and Evans case was offered, the largest ever for a Queensland homicide. A bus driver came forward to report that on Sunday, October 6, 1974, he'd been completing his route on Ipswich Road in Western Brisbane. As he passed the Oxley Police Academy, he saw two young women who matched the descriptions of
并可能遭到性侵犯，她们的尸体被相对公开地丢弃。这些相似之处似乎太强烈了，不可能是纯粹的巧合。这七名年轻女子是否有可能都成了同一个冷血杀手的受害者，公众称他为“黄金海岸搭便车杀手”？警方悬赏10万澳元征集有关威尔逊和埃文斯案的信息，这是昆士兰州凶杀案史上最高额的悬赏。一名巴士司机站出来报告说，1974年10月6日星期日，他正在布里斯班西部的伊普斯威奇路（Ipswich Road）上完成他的路线。当他经过奥克斯利警察学院（Oxley Police Academy）时，他看到两名年轻女子，她们的特征与
Lorraine and Wendy sitting on the side of the road. A faded light green EK Holden pulled over, and the women got in. Two men aged in their early 20s were sitting inside. The driver had shoulder-length, fair hair, and his passenger had an afro. This sighting coincided with the time that Lorraine and Wendy left Camp Hill, prompting detectives to conclude it was genuine. They appealed for anyone who had seen a similar vehicle in the area to come forward. The appeal caught the attention of Brisbane resident Anthony Doherty. On Sunday, October 6, 1974, he'd been parked in front of the Oxley Hotel when he overheard her two young women disagreeing about whether or not they should accept a ride.
洛林和温迪相符，坐在路边。一辆褪色的浅绿色EK霍顿（Holden）汽车靠边停下，两名女子上了车。车里坐着两名20岁出头的男子。司机留着齐肩的金发，乘客留着爆炸头。这次目击事件与洛林和温迪离开坎普山的时间相吻合，促使侦探们得出结论，这是真实的。他们呼吁任何在附近看到类似车辆的人站出来。这一呼吁引起了布里斯班居民安东尼·多尔蒂（Anthony Doherty）的注意。1974年10月6日星期日，他把车停在奥克斯利酒店（Oxley Hotel）前，无意中听到两名年轻女子在争论是否应该搭便车。
The women matched the description of Lorraine and Wendy. The shorter of the pair, presumably Wendy, was reluctant. Her friend said, I'm going whether you come or not. She walked over to the car parked next to Anthony's, a green Holden with a white top. In the passenger seat was a young male around 20 years old with dark hair and a round face. He had a scruffy look and a quote, silly grin on his face. Another male of similar age stood next to the Holden as though waiting for the girls to make up their minds. He was tanned with dark medium-length hair and a tattoo on his upper arm.
这两名女子与洛林和温迪的描述相符。两人中较矮的那位，推测是温迪，很不情愿。她的朋友说：“不管你来不来，我都要走。”她走到停在安东尼车旁的一辆白色车顶的绿色霍顿车前。副驾驶座上坐着一个20岁左右的年轻男性，深色头发，圆脸。他看起来很邋遢，脸上带着一种“傻笑”。另一名年龄相仿的男性站在霍顿车旁，似乎在等女孩们拿定主意。他皮肤黝黑，留着中等长度的深色头发，上臂有纹身。
Eventually, the shorter girl picked up her luggage and followed her friend into the back seat of the Holden. Anthony watched as the tanned male got into the driver's seat. The vehicle then sped off towards Ipswich Road, kicking pebbles in its wake. Anthony called the police to report this sighting, but the sergeant he spoke to thought he must have been mistaken. Convinced Lorraine and Wendy had fallen victim to the Gold Coast hitchhiker murderer, they believed the girls had actually been traveling in the opposite direction, down the Pacific Highway towards Sydney. Consequently, the sergeant wasn't interested in Anthony's sighting and didn't take a statement. This was despite the fact that the Holden had
最终，较矮的女孩拿起行李，跟着她的朋友坐进了霍顿车的后座。安东尼看着那个皮肤黝黑的男子坐进驾驶座。车辆随后加速驶向伊普斯威奇路，扬起一路碎石。安东尼打电话给警察报告了这次目击事件，但他交谈的那位警长认为他一定是看错了。他们确信洛林和温迪是黄金海岸搭便车杀手的受害者，认为女孩们实际上是朝相反的方向，沿着太平洋高速公路向悉尼方向行驶。因此，警长对安东尼的目击报告不感兴趣，也没有做笔录。尽管事实上那辆霍顿车
also been sighted in the vicinity of where Lorraine and Wendy's bodies were discovered. A local musician drove down Murphy's Creek Road every Saturday night for several weeks during September and October 1974. Each week, he noticed the car parked in the same spot, not far from where Lorraine and Wendy's bodies were eventually found. It was a light-colored 1964 EH Holden. Officer Ian Hamilton knew the vehicle well. Over his years working as a traffic cop, he'd pulled over a similar Holden several times. Although it was a common model, he remembered its distinct chrome wheels and the way it sat low at the front and and higher at the back. He'd issued defective tickets upon realizing there were no interior
也曾在发现洛林和温迪尸体的附近被看到过。一位当地音乐家在1974年9月和10月的几个星期里，每周六晚上都会开车经过墨菲溪路。每周，他都会注意到那辆车停在同一个地方，距离洛林和温迪的尸体最终被发现的地方不远。那是一辆浅色的1964年EH霍顿。伊恩·汉密尔顿警官很熟悉这辆车。在他担任交通警察的多年里，他曾多次拦下类似的霍顿车。虽然这是一个常见的车型，但他记得它独特的镀铬轮毂，以及它前低后高的姿态。他曾因发现后座没有内部
door handles or window winders in the back seat. He told detectives working the Wilson Evans case everything he knew about the vehicle and those associated with it. Regardless, these leads went nowhere and the case eventually went cold. Nine years passed with no further developments until an inquest was finally held in October 1985. No witnesses were called and no suspects were named. Based on the known facts, the coroner could only conclude that Lorraine and Wendy had been killed in Murphy's Creek by a person or person's unknown. Lorraine's brother, Eric Wilson, had an overwhelming need to uncover the truth of what happened, explaining, it's hard to accept that we might never ever find out. The thing is, you compound it every day.
门把手或车窗摇柄而开出过缺陷通知单。他告诉负责威尔逊-埃文斯案的侦探他所知道的关于这辆车及其相关人员的一切。无论如何，这些线索都没有结果，案件最终成了悬案。九年过去了，没有任何进一步的进展，直到1985年10月终于举行了死因研讯。没有传唤证人，也没有点名嫌疑人。根据已知事实，验尸官只能得出结论：洛林和温迪是在墨菲溪被身份不明的人杀害的。洛林的哥哥埃里克·威尔逊（Eric Wilson）有一种强烈的揭开真相的渴望，他解释说：“很难接受我们可能永远也找不到真相。问题是，你每天都在加重这种痛苦。”
It makes it worse in your mind if that's possible. All those unanswered questions, they're not knowing. You walk around every day with a mountain of fear sitting on your shoulder. Three years after the inquest in October 1988, Detective Senior Constable Paul Rouge of the Toowoomba Criminal Investigation Branch received a word that an inmate in New South Wales had implicated two men in the Wilson Evans homicide. According to this witness, several years after Lorraine and Wendy were killed, he'd been drinking with two acquaintances when the subject of the nurse's murders came up. One of the men allegedly admitted that they'd picked the pair up to drink with them, to which the other allegedly responded. Yeah, but more than that happened, didn't it?
“如果可能的话，这会让你的内心更加煎熬。所有那些未解的问题，那种不知道的感觉。你每天都背负着一座恐惧的大山在行走。”在1985年研讯三年后的1988年10月，图文巴刑事调查分部的保罗·鲁日（Paul Rouge）高级警探接到消息，称新南威尔士州的一名囚犯指控两名男子参与了威尔逊-埃文斯谋杀案。据这名证人称，在洛林和温迪被杀几年后，他曾与两名熟人喝酒，当时提到了护士谋杀案的话题。其中一名男子据称承认他们曾载过那两人去喝酒，另一名男子据称回应道：
We screwed them and killed them. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support case file to continue to deliver quality content. The witness named the man is Toowoomba locals Donald Laurie and Trevor Hilton. This confession turned out to be a bust. Trevor Hilton had been incarcerated at the time Lorraine and Wendy were killed. Still, Detective Rouge's interest was peaked. He requested the Wilson and Evans case file to find all it contained was a few notes and newspaper clippings. There were no witness statements, no running sheets, nothing.
“是啊，但发生的不止这些，对吧？我们强奸了她们并杀了她们。”《案件档案》稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持《案件档案》继续提供高质量的内容。证人点名那两人是图文巴当地人唐纳德·劳里（Donald Laurie）和特雷弗·希尔顿（Trevor Hilton）。这次供述结果是一场空。特雷弗·希尔顿在洛林和温迪被杀时正在服刑。尽管如此，鲁日警探的兴趣还是被激发了。他调取了威尔逊和埃文斯案的档案，发现里面只有几张笔记和剪报。没有证人陈述，没有行动记录，什么都没有。
Rouge was left to piece together the case using the scant paperwork and limited physical evidence. The more he learned, the more shocked he became. The inmate's confession wasn't the first time that the names Hilton and Laurie had been mentioned in relation to the murders. The extended Laurie and Hilton families were interrelated by blood and marriage. They had lived around Toowoomba for decades, where some members of the families had earned a fierce reputation for being violent and dangerous. Local police were very familiar with several members of the two families due to their history of alcohol abuse, domestic violence, and run-ins with the law. Following the discovery of Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans remains,
鲁日只能利用稀少的文书工作和有限的物证来拼凑案件。他了解得越多，就越感到震惊。囚犯的供述并不是第一次提到希尔顿和劳里这两个名字与谋杀案有关。希尔顿和劳里家族的大家庭在血缘和婚姻上是相互关联的。他们在图文巴周围生活了几十年，其中一些家庭成员因暴力和危险而声名狼藉。当地警方对这两个家族的几名成员非常熟悉，因为他们有酗酒、家庭暴力和触犯法律的历史。在发现洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯的遗骸后，
three separate people had suggested police look into the Hilton and Laurie crew. It was well known that some of the young men associated with the group had a habit of picking up teenage girls for sex, whether consensual or by force. They'd go as far as grabbing them off the street and throwing them into the boot or back seat of their cars. Survivors described that handles and window-winders had been removed from the back doors to prevent their escape. The group were also known for throwing alcohol-fuelled parties out in the bush, including at Murphy's Creek. Despite this information, none of these men had been questioned at any point, for reasons Detective Rouge couldn't ascertain.
有三个人分别建议警方调查希尔顿和劳里团伙。众所周知，与该团伙相关的一些年轻男子有搭讪少女进行性行为的习惯，无论是自愿还是强迫。他们甚至会把她们从街上抓走，扔进汽车的后备箱或后座。幸存者描述说，后门的把手和车窗摇柄被拆除了，以防止她们逃跑。该团伙还以在灌木丛中举办酒精驱动的派对而闻名，包括在墨菲溪。尽管有这些信息，但由于鲁日警探无法确定的原因，这些人从未受到过任何询问。
Back when the bodies of Lorraine and Wendy were found, a local couple had reported a strange encounter they'd had on the Toowoomba Range in early October of 1974. Brian and Velma had been driving home from visiting their sick infant daughter in hospital when they noticed a vehicle parked in a small turnoff on the left-hand side of the road. It was a pale green E.J. or E.H. Holden with a white top. Judging by its angle, the Holden looked as though it had abruptly skidded to a stop. Both passenger side doors were open. Towards the back of the car, a man was throttling a young woman while trying to force her inside. About 20 metres away, another man was marching a second young woman towards the Holden,
早在洛林和温迪的尸体被发现时，一对当地夫妇就报告了他们在1974年10月初在图文巴山脉遇到的一件奇怪的事情。布莱恩（Brian）和维尔玛（Velma）在从医院探望生病的婴儿女儿回家的路上，注意到一辆车停在路左侧的一个小岔道上。那是一辆白色车顶的浅绿色EJ或EH霍顿。从角度来看，这辆霍顿看起来像是突然急刹车停下的。副驾驶侧的两扇门都开着。在车后部，一名男子正在掐住一名年轻女子的脖子，试图强迫她上车。大约20米外，另一名男子正押着第二名年轻女子走向霍顿，
pinning her arms behind her back. The woman looked directly at Brian and Velma and screamed, help me, oh God, help me. Velma ordered her husband to stop and he slowed down a little further ahead. Brian and Velma looked back. In the front seat of the Holden, they could see two other men and a third woman. Velma and Brian wanted to offer assistance, but they had their three-year-old daughter in the back seat and were scared they might put her or themselves in danger. Overcome with fear, they decided to keep driving. They soon passed a pay phone, but decided not to call the police in case the men drove past and suspected what they were doing.
把她的双臂反剪在身后。那名女子直视着布莱恩和维尔玛，尖叫道：“救救我，哦上帝，救救我。”维尔玛命令丈夫停车，他在前方一点减速了。布莱恩和维尔玛回头看。在霍顿的前座，他们可以看到另外两名男子和第三名女子。维尔玛和布莱恩想提供帮助，但他们的三岁女儿在后座，他们担心这可能会让她或他们自己陷入危险。恐惧战胜了理智，他们决定继续开车。他们很快经过一个公用电话，但决定不报警，以防那些人开车经过并怀疑他们的行为。
Instead, they went home. The next morning, Velma reported the incident to a police officer whom they knew. The officer wasn't too worried. There hadn't been any news of any assaults the night prior or missing person reports filed. When the bodies of Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans were discovered not far from where they witnessed the altercation, Brian and Velma were convinced they had seen something significant. They reported their concerns to the same officer they'd initially spoken to who looked into their claims. Apparently, hospital admission records for Brian and Velma's sick daughter didn't match up with the alleged timing of Lorraine and Wendy's murder.
相反，他们回家了。第二天早上，维尔玛向他们认识的一名警官报告了这件事。那名警官并不太担心。前一天晚上没有任何袭击新闻，也没有失踪人口报告。当洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯的尸体在他们目击冲突地点不远处被发现时，布莱恩和维尔玛确信他们看到了重要的事情。他们向最初交谈的那位警官报告了他们的担忧，警官调查了他们的说法。显然，布莱恩和维尔玛生病女儿的住院记录与洛林和温迪被谋杀的所谓时间不符。
Their accounts were therefore eliminated as a potential lead in the investigation. Detective Rouge wasn't so sure. He showed the couple a photo lineup of 16 men. Despite over a decade passing, Brian confidently pointed to one photo. It was Wayne Hilton. Better known by his nickname Boogie, Wayne was a prominent member of the Hilton Laurie clan. 19 years old at the time Lorraine and Wendy were killed, he had a reputation for turning violent if he didn't get his way. He reportedly had a tyre lever stored under the front seat of his car that he wielded as a weapon. Some of Wayne Hilton's close cohorts included friends and relatives, Alan Shorty Laurie, Alan Unge Laurie, Donald Laurie, Desmond Hilton, Larry Charles and Jimmy O'Neill.
因此，他们的陈述被排除在调查的潜在线索之外。鲁日警探并不确定。他向这对夫妇展示了一张包含16名男子的照片排查表。尽管过去了十多年，布莱恩还是自信地指出了其中一张照片。那是韦恩·希尔顿（Wayne Hilton）。韦恩以绰号“布吉”（Boogie）而闻名，是希尔顿-劳里家族的重要成员。洛林和温迪被杀时他19岁，以如果不顺心就会变得暴力而闻名。据报道，他的车前座下藏着一根轮胎撬棍，他将其作为武器使用。韦恩·希尔顿的一些亲密同伙包括朋友和亲戚，艾伦·“矮子”·劳里（Alan Shorty Laurie）、艾伦·“昂格”·劳里（Alan Unge Laurie）、唐纳德·劳里、德斯蒙德·希尔顿（Desmond Hilton）、拉里·查尔斯（Larry Charles）和吉米·奥尼尔（Jimmy O'Neill）。
Due to their proclivity for heavy drinking and fighting, many of the men were banned from every pub into Wumba. Another member of their crew named Kingsley Hunt didn't drink. He took on the role of designated driver and ferried the gang to parties and pubs out of town. There were several vehicles that could be attributed to the crew. One was a pale green Holden with a white top. Detective Rouge turned his focus to one of the only pieces of physical evidence at the crime scene, the cord used to bind Lorraine and Wendy. It was fairly commonplace, much like the kind used on Venetian blinds, but Rouge had his suspicions about where it might have originated. He visited the Darling Downs Bacon Company into Wumba. The pig processing plant was one of the largest in the
由于他们倾向于酗酒和打架，许多人被图文巴的每家酒吧禁止进入。他们团伙中另一名成员名叫金斯利·亨特（Kingsley Hunt），他不喝酒。他担任指定司机，负责把团伙成员送到城外的派对和酒吧。有几辆车可以归属于该团伙。其中一辆是白色车顶的浅绿色霍顿。鲁日警探将注意力转向犯罪现场仅有的几件物证之一，即用于捆绑洛林和温迪的绳子。这很常见，就像百叶窗上用的那种，但鲁日对它的来源有怀疑。他拜访了图文巴的达令唐斯培根公司（Darling Downs Bacon Company）。这家猪肉加工厂是该州最大的工厂之一，雇佣了许多当地人。鲁日向一名员工展示了绳子，问他是否觉得眼熟。员工说是的，工厂里用类似类型的绳子来挂培根。这是一个重大的发现。韦恩·希尔顿在洛林和温迪被杀时曾在达令唐斯培根公司工作。鲁日警探与另一名名叫尼尔（Neil）的男子交谈，他曾与韦恩·希尔顿断断续续地工作过几年。据尼尔说，有一天韦恩突然宣布他很快就得辞职。当尼尔问为什么时，韦恩据称说：“你看到报纸上我们车的照片了吗？他们盯上我们了。你应该听说过山那边护士被谋杀的事吧。”
state and employed many of the town's locals. Rouge presented the cord to an employee and asked if it looked familiar. The employee said yes, a similar type of cord was used in the factory to hang bacon. This was a significant revelation. Wayne Hilton had been employed at the Darling Downs Bacon Company around the time Lorraine and Wendy were killed. Detective Rouge spoke with another man named Neil who had worked with Wayne Hilton on and off for several years. According to Neil, one day Wayne suddenly announced that he'd soon have to quit his job. When Neil asked why, Wayne allegedly said, did you see the picture of our cars in the paper? They're right onto us. You would have heard about the nurses being murdered a bit over the range.
并雇佣了镇上的许多当地人。鲁日向一名员工展示了这根绳子，并询问他是否觉得眼熟。该员工回答说是的，工厂里曾使用过类似类型的绳子来悬挂培根。这是一个重大的发现。韦恩·希尔顿在洛林和温迪遇害前后曾受雇于达令唐斯培根公司。鲁日警探与另一名曾与韦恩·希尔顿断断续续共事多年的男子尼尔进行了交谈。据尼尔说，有一天韦恩突然宣布他很快就得辞职。当尼尔问他为什么时，韦恩声称说，你看到报纸上我们车的照片了吗？他们正盯着我们呢。你应该听说过护士在山脉那边被谋杀的事吧。
May and the brother done that. Neil assumed Wayne was talking about his brother Trevor, but realized he'd been in jail at the time. Instead, he figured Wayne was talking about one of his uncles who were close in age to Wayne and with whom he had a close relationship. According to Neil, Wayne went on to explain that the nurses had gotten away from them and gave them, quote, a bit of trouble. He said he was afraid of getting caught and asked for advice. Neil asked why he did it, to which Wayne responded, full of piss and bad manners. Although Neil found it odd, he didn't really believe what Wayne was saying,
“我和我兄弟干的。”尼尔以为韦恩说的是他兄弟特雷弗，但意识到他当时在监狱里。相反，他认为韦恩说的是他的一位叔叔，他们与韦恩年龄相仿，且关系密切。据尼尔说，韦恩继续解释说，护士们从他们手中逃脱了，给他们造成了“一点麻烦”。他说他害怕被抓，并寻求建议。尼尔问他为什么要这么做，韦恩回答说：“喝多了，没教养。”虽然尼尔觉得很奇怪，但他并没有真正相信韦恩所说的话，
even when he went through with quitting his job. Neil said Wayne mentioned his involvement in the murders on several other occasions. But it was only years later that Neil suspected he might actually be telling the truth. Wayne Hilton's cohort, Alan Laurie, who went by the nickname Shorty, had also worked at the Darling Downs Bacon Company. Shorty turned 22 the day Lorraine and Wendy were murdered. Perhaps the most violent of the group, he was feared by many and labelled by some as a psychopath. Shorty's violence knew no boundaries. He once punched and stomped on his own mother and had bit his father's ear off over a fight about a sausage. Detective Rouge visited Alan Shorty Laurie at home and asked if he could come by
即使在他真的辞职之后。尼尔说韦恩在其他几次场合也提到过他参与了谋杀案。但直到多年后，尼尔才怀疑他可能真的在说实话。韦恩·希尔顿的同伙艾伦·劳里（绰号“矮子”）也曾在达令唐斯培根公司工作。洛林和温迪被谋杀那天，“矮子”正好22岁。他可能是该团伙中最暴力的人，许多人对他感到恐惧，有些人称他为精神病患者。“矮子”的暴力没有底线。他曾经因为香肠的争吵而殴打并踩踏自己的母亲，还咬掉了父亲的耳朵。鲁日警探拜访了艾伦·“矮子”·劳里家，问他是否可以来
the station to answer some questions. He made no mention of Lorraine and Wendy, simply saying he wanted to discuss a car that Shorty had previously owned. Shorty became highly anxious, but reluctantly agreed to come by later that day. He arrived at the station hand in hand with his wife. Shorty was clearly agitated, almost to a point of panic. Everything about his demeanour was in complete contrast to the menacing character that Detective Rouge had been led to expect. When placed in an interview room away from his wife, Shorty entered a full-blown state of panic. He started breathing heavily and frothing at the mouth. When told, we need to ask you some questions about your involvement in the nurse's murders,
警局回答一些问题。他没有提到洛林和温迪，只是说想讨论一下“矮子”以前拥有的一辆车。“矮子”变得非常焦虑，但勉强同意当天晚些时候过来。他与妻子手牵手来到警局。显然，“矮子”非常不安，几乎到了恐慌的地步。他的一切举止都与鲁日警探预期的那种威胁性人物完全相反。当被带进远离妻子的审讯室时，“矮子”陷入了全面的恐慌状态。他开始大口喘气，口吐白沫。当被告知“我们需要问你一些关于你参与护士谋杀案的问题”时，
Alan Shorty Laurie leapt to his feet and started bellowing like a bull. It was so loud that other officers rushed to the interview room to see what was going on. He repeatedly cried out, I didn't do it, I didn't do it. His distress was so extreme that Detective Rouge couldn't continue with his questioning. He requested that Shorty return to the station later on for a formal interview. Instead, Shorty hired a lawyer who advised that his client wouldn't be answering any further questions. Detective Rouge was eventually transferred to another district, which meant he could no longer have any involvement with the Wilson and Evans case. He collated all the information and witness statements he'd obtained and sent them to
艾伦·“矮子”·劳里跳了起来，像公牛一样咆哮。声音太大，其他警官冲进审讯室看发生了什么事。他反复大喊：“不是我干的，不是我干的。”他的痛苦如此强烈，以至于鲁日警探无法继续审讯。他要求“矮子”稍后再回警局进行正式审讯。相反，“矮子”聘请了一名律师，律师建议他的客户不再回答任何进一步的问题。鲁日警探最终被调到另一个区，这意味着他无法再参与威尔逊和埃文斯案。他整理了所有获得的信息和证人陈述，并将它们发送给
the homicide squad, hoping someone would pick up where he left off. Although tips continued to come through over the years, things soon came to a standstill. No arrests were made. In fact, none of the remaining persons of interest were even questioned. Lorraine's brother Eric spent his adult life tormented by the murders. In 2003 he wrote a book about the case titled The Echo of Silent Screams. It sparked renewed interest in the case, putting pressure on the Queensland Police Commissioner to reopen the investigation. The job went to Detective Inspector Kerry Johnson, a former member of the Homicide Squad known for his success raid at Solving Cold Cases. For the first time, all the case material was reviewed
凶杀组，希望有人能接手他未竟的工作。虽然多年来不断有线索传来，但事情很快陷入了停滞。没有进行任何逮捕。事实上，剩下的相关人员甚至都没有受到询问。洛林的哥哥埃里克一生都被谋杀案折磨。2003年，他写了一本关于此案的书，名为《沉默尖叫的回声》（The Echo of Silent Screams）。这引发了人们对该案的重新关注，向昆士兰警察局长施压，要求重新调查。这项工作交给了凯里·约翰逊（Kerry Johnson）侦探督察，他曾是凶杀组的一员，以成功侦破悬案而闻名。这是第一次，所有的案件材料都被重新审查。
in thorough detail. It was abundantly clear that poor policing, lack of investigative resources, and conflicting witness statements had contributed to Lorraine and Wendy's killers going unpunished. Motivated to finally find closure for the Wilson and Evans families, Detective Johnson said about reinterviewing all of the key witnesses and persons of interest, piecing together the known information and trying to fill in any gaps. It appeared that the circumstances surrounding Lorraine and Wendy's murders were an open secret amongst many people in Toowoomba. Over the years, others had reported worthwhile information that implicated the same group of men. The morning after the murders, Wayne Hilton's neighbour claimed to have seen him ripping the
细节详尽。显而易见，糟糕的警务工作、调查资源的匮乏以及相互矛盾的证词，导致洛林和温迪的凶手逍遥法外。为了给威尔逊和埃文斯家族一个交代，约翰逊警探着手重新询问所有关键证人和相关人员，拼凑已知信息并试图填补任何空白。洛林和温迪谋杀案的真相似乎在图文巴的许多人中已是公开的秘密。多年来，其他人也曾报告过有价值的信息，指向同一伙人。谋杀案发生的第二天，韦恩·希尔顿的邻居声称看到他正在撕掉
carpet out of the backseat of a Green Holden. When she asked what he was doing, Wayne told her to mind her own business. The neighbour left but couldn't ignore what she saw on the carpet, a large reddish-brown stain that looked like blood. Another associate of the group, Desmond Hilton, recalled that one morning in October 1974, Wayne Hilton and Donald Lorry were drinking at his house when a light green E. H. Holden pulled up. Inside were Alan Shorty Lorry, Jimmy O'Neill, Larry Charles and Alan Unge Lorry. They revealed that they'd quote, given two girls are hiding down the bottom of the range. According to Desmond, Shorty bragged and demonstrated how they kicked and stomped on the girls.
一辆绿色霍顿汽车后座的地毯。当她问他在做什么时，韦恩叫她少管闲事。邻居离开了，但无法忽视她在地毯上看到的东西——一大片红褐色的污渍，看起来像血。该团伙的另一名成员德斯蒙德·希尔顿回忆说，1974年10月的一个早晨，韦恩·希尔顿和唐纳德·洛里正在他家喝酒，这时一辆浅绿色的E.H.霍顿汽车开了过来。车里坐着艾伦·“矮子”·洛里、吉米·奥尼尔、拉里·查尔斯和艾伦·“昂格”·洛里。他们透露说，他们“把两个女孩藏在山脉底部”。据德斯蒙德说，“矮子”吹嘘并演示了他们是如何踢打和践踏这些女孩的。
Desmond claimed that the men offered him beer in exchange for cleaning their car. He agreed, too scared to say no. Across the backseat was a light smear of blood, as though an injured person had been dragged across it. According to Desmond, Wayne Hilton and Donald Lorry then went back to the range to check on the girls. When they returned, they had blood on their hands. It was only years later when Desmond found out about the murders of Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans that he realized the group had been talking about the nurses. Donald Lorry had seemed terrified ever since, and it now makes sense why. He'd admitted to Desmond that he'd taken a ring from one of the girls that he'd later sold for beer money at the local pub.
德斯蒙德声称，这些人用啤酒作为报酬让他清理车子。他同意了，因为太害怕而不敢拒绝。后座上有一道淡淡的血迹，就像一个受伤的人被拖过一样。据德斯蒙德说，韦恩·希尔顿和唐纳德·洛里随后回到山脉去查看那些女孩。当他们回来时，手上沾满了血。直到多年后，当德斯蒙德得知洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯的谋杀案时，他才意识到这伙人当时谈论的是那两名护士。从那以后，唐纳德·洛里一直显得非常恐惧，现在看来原因显而易见。他曾向德斯蒙德承认，他从其中一个女孩身上拿走了一枚戒指，后来在当地酒吧卖掉换了啤酒钱。
While sick in hospital years later, Donald Lorry allegedly told a friend, we killed the nurses. I was there. I didn't do it. According to this witness, Donald directly implicated Wayne Hilton, Unge Lorry and Shorty Lorry, but also said that three or four carloads of people were involved. When asked why he hadn't gone to police, Donald apparently replied that the others would have killed him if he had spoken up. Another associate had once seen gang member Lorry Charles crying, which was completely out of character. When asked what was wrong, Lorry allegedly responded, it was two years today that them girls got killed at Murphy's Creek.
多年后，唐纳德·洛里在医院病重时，据称曾对一位朋友说：“是我们杀了那些护士。我在场。但我没动手。”据这位证人称，唐纳德直接指控了韦恩·希尔顿、“昂格”·洛里和“矮子”·洛里，但也表示有三四车人参与其中。当被问及为什么没有报警时，唐纳德回答说，如果他说了，其他人会杀了他。另一位熟人曾看到帮派成员拉里·查尔斯哭泣，这完全不符合他的性格。当被问及发生了什么事时，拉里据称回答说：“今天正好是那两个女孩在墨菲溪被杀两周年。”
Lorry then apparently confessed to having picked up Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans with Wayne Hilton, Shorty Lorry, Donald Lorry and Jimmy O'Neill. They took the women into the bush, at which point Unge Lorry, Desmond Hilton and a few of their friends arrived. The whole group, excluding Lorry, then took turns raping and bashing the women. The next morning, Wayne Hilton and Shorty Lorry had a whispered conversation. Then, quote, they both walked towards the girls, picked up a big stick each and just wailed and wailed into them. Fear of retaliation had kept some silent, but the poor policing couldn't be ignored. Back in 1974, a 19-year-old woman had accepted a lift home from Shorty Lorry and one of his friends.
拉里随后似乎承认，他和韦恩·希尔顿、“矮子”·洛里、唐纳德·洛里以及吉米·奥尼尔一起接走了洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯。他们把这些女性带到丛林中，这时“昂格”·洛里、德斯蒙德·希尔顿和他们的一些朋友也到了。除了拉里之外，整个团伙轮流强奸并殴打这些女性。第二天早上，韦恩·希尔顿和“矮子”·洛里低声交谈。然后，引用他们的话，“他们俩走向女孩，每人捡起一根大棍子，对着她们猛打。”对报复的恐惧让一些人保持沉默，但糟糕的警务工作不容忽视。早在1974年，一名19岁的女性曾搭乘“矮子”·洛里和他朋友的车回家。
Instead of taking her home, she claimed they pulled over and took turns raping her in the back seat. She reported the incident and was examined by a medical officer, but never heard another word about it and was too scared to follow it up with the police. This was just one in a long series of similar allegations. Detective Inspector Kerry Johnson was deeply troubled by this information and the fact that nothing had been done to reprimand those involved. But perhaps most concerning was there were other innocent bystanders that had witnessed the attack against Lorraine and Wendy as it unfolded. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
她声称，他们没有送她回家，而是把车停在路边，在后座轮流强奸了她。她报告了这起事件并接受了医官的检查，但之后再也没有收到任何消息，她太害怕了，不敢再向警方跟进。这仅仅是一系列类似指控中的一个。克里·约翰逊警督对这些信息以及没有任何人因参与其中而受到惩罚的事实感到非常不安。但最令人担忧的或许是，还有其他无辜的旁观者目睹了针对洛林和温迪的袭击过程。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. On Sunday, October 6, 1974, married couple Neil and Jocelyn had been driving down the Toowoomba Range when one of their children fell car sick. They pulled into a turn-off, only to find two cars already parked there. Clothing was strewn on the side of the road, leading Neil and Jocelyn to believe the two cars had been involved in an accident. Two men were escorting a young woman into a black Ford Falcon as though offering her assistance. One of the men was scrawny and ill looking and dressed all in white.
感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持了Case File继续提供高质量的内容。1974年10月6日星期日，已婚夫妇尼尔和乔斯林正开车经过图文巴山脉，他们的一个孩子晕车了。他们驶入一个岔路口，却发现那里已经停了两辆车。路边散落着衣物，这让尼尔和乔斯林认为这两辆车发生了事故。两名男子正护送一名年轻女子进入一辆黑色福特猎鹰轿车，仿佛在提供帮助。其中一名男子瘦骨嶙峋，看起来病恹恹的，全身穿着白色衣服。
This fit the description of the designated driver of the Hilton and Laurie crew, Kingsley Hunt. His job at a pest control company required him to wear a white uniform. The young woman turned to face Neil and Jocelyn. That's when they realized the men weren't helping her at all. They were forcing her into the car. The young woman screamed, please help me. Another young woman was in the backseat of the other car, a light-colored Holden. She was wrestling with a dark-haired man aged in his early to mid-20s. He attempted to restrain her as she lent forward and yelled for help. Another man was pacing around nervously outside the vehicle with his hands on his head.
这符合希尔顿和洛里团伙指定司机金斯利·亨特的描述。他在一家害虫防治公司的工作要求他穿白色制服。那名年轻女子转过身面对尼尔和乔斯林。就在那时，他们意识到这些人根本不是在帮她。他们是在强迫她上车。那名年轻女子尖叫道：“请救救我。”另一名年轻女子在另一辆车——一辆浅色霍顿车的后座上。她正在与一名20岁出头、黑头发的男子搏斗。当她向前倾身大声呼救时，他试图制服她。另一名男子在车外焦躁不安地踱步，双手抱头。
Too scared to stop, Neil and Jocelyn continued down the range. They considered reporting the incident to the police, but instead they drove onwards, convincing themselves that it was just a lover's tiff of some kind. They decided to let it go unless they heard anything in the news over the next few days, which they never did. Another married couple, Vivian and Rose, were driving down the range at dusk when they saw a car pulled over on the left-hand side of the road. A man and young woman were lying across the front bonnet in what appeared to be a lover's embrace. Thinking it was a strange place to stop
因为太害怕而不敢停车，尼尔和乔斯林继续沿着山路行驶。他们考虑过向警方报告这起事件，但最终还是继续开车，说服自己这只是某种情侣间的争吵。他们决定除非在接下来的几天里在新闻中听到什么，否则就不再追究，但他们从未听到任何消息。另一对已婚夫妇维维安和罗斯在黄昏时分开车下山，看到一辆车停在路左侧。一名男子和一名年轻女子横躺在引擎盖上，看起来像是情侣拥抱。他们觉得这是一个奇怪的停车地点
for a cuddle, they soon realized it wasn't a romantic moment at all. The man was restraining the woman who was trying to break free. At that moment, another young woman raced out onto the road screaming for help. A dark-haired man of average height and build was chasing close behind her, undeterred by the fact that Vivian and Rose had seen what was going on. Vivian applied the brakes, but the couple had their three young children in the backseat, so Rose urged him to keep driving. They drove to the nearest police station, where the officer on duty said they'd contact the Tawumba police to send a patrol car down the range to check it out. Vivian and Rose never
去亲热，但很快意识到这根本不是什么浪漫时刻。那名男子正在制服试图挣脱的女子。就在这时，另一名年轻女子冲到路上尖叫求救。一名中等身材、黑头发的男子紧追在后，完全不在乎维维安和罗斯已经看到了这一切。维维安踩下了刹车，但这对夫妇的三个年幼孩子在后座，所以罗斯催促他继续开车。他们开车去了最近的警察局，值班警官说他们会联系图文巴警方，派巡逻车下山去查看。维维安和罗斯再也没有
heard another word about it. When the bodies of Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans were found, Rose contacted police again. She did so again when the case was featured on Australia's most wanted in 1989. No one ever so much as asked for her contact details, let alone took a statement. Norma was preparing dinner alone at her home in the Tawumba Ranges in early October 1974, when she heard a panicked woman's voice. It was coming from her back door. Norma found a young woman with light brown hair standing there. She begged for Norma's help, saying she had just been at a party with a group of people whom she now wanted to get away from. She had escaped from their vehicle and needed somewhere safe to stay for a while.
听到关于此事的任何消息。当洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯的尸体被发现时，罗斯再次联系了警方。1989年该案件在《澳大利亚头号通缉犯》节目中播出时，她又联系了一次。没有人甚至要求提供她的联系方式，更不用说做笔录了。1974年10月初，诺玛独自在图文巴山脉的家中准备晚餐时，听到一个惊慌失措的女人的声音。声音来自她的后门。诺玛发现一个留着浅棕色头发的年轻女子站在那里。她恳求诺玛帮助，说她刚才和一群人参加了一个聚会，现在想逃离他们。她从他们的车里逃了出来，需要一个安全的地方待一会儿。
Norma didn't know what to do. Her husband was due to arrive home, so she told the young woman she could wait inside until he returned. They'd figure things out from there. But the woman became increasingly frantic. She said she couldn't wait around because the group had her friend, and they were going to kill her if she didn't go back. Norma told the woman she could sneak out the back way, who in turn responded, they would probably find me anyway. Norma offered to call the police, but the woman declined, saying, I better go.
诺玛不知道该怎么办。她的丈夫快要到家了，所以她告诉那个年轻女子可以在里面等他回来。他们会从那里想办法。但那个女人变得越来越狂乱。她说她不能等，因为那伙人抓住了她的朋友，如果她不回去，他们就会杀了她。诺玛告诉那个女人可以从后门溜走，对方回答说：“他们大概还是会找到我的。”诺玛提出报警，但那个女人拒绝了，说：“我还是走吧。”
Norma returned to her kitchen only to hear a loud scream. She rushed to a front window where she saw a car idling outside. The woman who had just been in her house was struggling with a young man who had a long, wavy, dark hair. He struck the woman across the face as he tried to force her into the back seat of the car. Norma could see a second young woman in the back of the vehicle. She too was in the throes of a struggle with another man. It looked as though she was trying to get out, but the man wouldn't let her leave. At that moment, Norma's husband pulled into the driveway. He had also witnessed the struggle
诺玛回到厨房，却听到一声尖叫。她冲到前窗，看到外面停着一辆车。刚才在她家里的那个女人正在和一个留着长波浪黑发的年轻男子搏斗。当他试图强行把她塞进车后座时，他打了那个女人的脸。诺玛可以看到车后座还有第二个年轻女子。她也在和另一个男人搏斗。看起来她试图逃跑，但那个男人不让她离开。就在这时，诺玛的丈夫把车开进了车道。他也目睹了这场搏斗
and headed inside to ask Norma what was going on. She filled him in, but he responded, quote, it was probably just a domestic. The couple returned to the front window. By then, the men, the women, and the car were gone. Two weeks later, Norma was reading the newspaper when she came across a photo of Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans. Norma immediately recognized Lorraine as the young woman who had knocked on her door and Wendy as the woman in the back seat of the car. She wanted to contact the police, but her husband warned her not to get involved. When Lorraine and Wendy's bodies were discovered, Norma informed her parents what she had witnessed
并走进屋里问诺玛发生了什么事。她告诉了他情况，但他回答说：“那可能只是家庭纠纷。”这对夫妇回到前窗。那时，男人们、女人们和车都已经不见了。两周后，诺玛在看报纸时，看到了一张洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯的照片。诺玛立刻认出洛林就是那个敲她门的年轻女子，温迪就是车后座上的那个女人。她想联系警方，但她的丈夫警告她不要卷入其中。当洛林和温迪的尸体被发现时，诺玛告诉了她的父母她所目睹的一切
two years earlier. They agreed that she should obey her husband's wishes and not get involved. Memories of the women's cries for help haunted Norma for years. By the time a segment about the case appeared on Australia's Most Wanted in 1989, Norma and her family had relocated into state. Unable to keep it to herself any longer, she finally contacted the police. They had her identify Lorraine and Wendy from a photo, but whether anything else was done beyond that is unknown. When Lorraine's brother Eric heard about this, Eric heard about this, he was crushed. He remarked, My sister was standing in front of a woman who was the same age as her mother.
两年前的事情。他们同意她应该听从丈夫的意愿，不要卷入其中。多年来，那些女性求救的尖叫声一直困扰着诺玛。到1989年该案件在《澳大利亚头号通缉犯》中出现时，诺玛和她的家人已经搬到了州外。无法再保守秘密，她终于联系了警方。他们让她从照片中辨认出洛林和温迪，但除此之外是否还做了其他事情就不得而知了。当洛林的兄弟埃里克听到这个消息时，他崩溃了。他评论道：“我姐姐当时站在一个和她母亲同龄的女人面前。”
She was looking for a mother's protection, a mother's advice on what she should do. She got nothing. She was on her own. There is a famous saying, Evil exists when good men or women do nothing. How true a statement that is. For almost 40 years, Lorraine Wilson's family had tried to move on with their lives, but the lack of closure made it impossible. By 2012, Lorraine's father was suffering from dementia. Her brother Eric wanted answers not only for himself, but for his elderly parents. With all the new information that had come to light since the initial inquest in 1985,
“她在寻求一位母亲的保护，寻求一位母亲关于她该怎么做的建议。但她什么也没得到。她孤立无援。”有一句名言：“当好人袖手旁观时，邪恶就会滋生。”这句话是多么真实。近40年来，洛林·威尔逊的家人一直试图继续他们的生活，但缺乏真相让这变得不可能。到2012年，洛林的父亲患上了痴呆症。她的兄弟埃里克不仅为自己，也为他年迈的父母寻求答案。随着1985年最初的调查以来所有新信息的出现，
the Wilson family felt that Lorraine and Wendy at the very least deserved another inquest. Lorraine's mother Betty wrote to the coroner, To this day, no one has been held accountable for the murder of Lorraine, my daughter, and her friend Wendy. It is important to me, my family, and the public at large to have these suspects fully accountable and have them named in the public domain. For the sake of justice and history, I feel it is important that with all the new evidence in this investigation to be laid out in clear view for all to see. I wish to rest in peace, and I urge for the sake of the girls who do not have a voice, as well as my own, for you to convene a coronial inquest to wear these findings.
威尔逊一家觉得洛林和温迪至少应该得到另一次调查。洛林的母亲贝蒂写信给验尸官：“直到今天，没有人为我女儿洛林和她朋友温迪的谋杀案负责。对我、我的家人和广大公众来说，让这些嫌疑人完全负责并公开他们的名字非常重要。为了正义和历史，我觉得重要的是，随着这项调查中所有新证据的出现，应该清晰地呈现给所有人看。我希望安息，我恳请为了那些没有发言权的女孩，也为了我自己，请您召开一次验尸调查来公布这些发现。”
Three days after writing the letter, Betty was working alone in the garden when she slipped and severed an artery. She tried to make it back to the house, but the blood loss was too severe. Betty passed away without ever seeing justice served for her daughter. Betty's request for accountability was denied, much to the outrage of the public. Media rallied around Eric Wilson, propelling the murders back in the headlines. The coroner succumbed to the public pressure, and it was announced that a new inquest would be held with the aim of determining whether there was enough evidence to warrant a trial. By this point there was no shortage of witnesses. Some had seen Lorraine and Wendy accepting a ride, others had seen them trying
写完这封信三天后，贝蒂独自在花园里工作时滑倒并割断了动脉。她试图回到屋里，但失血过多。贝蒂去世了，没能看到她女儿的正义得到伸张。贝蒂要求追究责任的请求被拒绝，这引起了公众的愤怒。媒体聚集在埃里克·威尔逊周围，将这起谋杀案重新推向头条。验尸官屈服于公众压力，宣布将进行新的调查，目的是确定是否有足够的证据支持审判。到这一点，证人并不缺乏。有些人看到洛林和温迪搭车，另一些人看到她们试图
to escape their attackers. Others had received confessions or incriminating statements from the suspected perpetrators. The problem was inconsistencies were rife. Some had described the perpetrator's car as an EJ Holden, others said an EH Holden, both remarkably similar models. The physical description of the men involved also varied, making it difficult to pinpoint which individuals were responsible for which acts. A full forensic review was ordered on all available evidence, but there was even less to go by than originally thought. There were hopes that the cord used to hog tile Lorraine and Wendy would reveal traces of the perpetrator's DNA, but the tests proved negative. Some of the evidence had been disposed of in 2010, while other items had
逃离袭击者。还有一些人收到了嫌疑人的供词或罪证陈述。问题是前后矛盾的情况比比皆是。有些人将肇事者的车描述为EJ霍顿，另一些人说是EH霍顿，两者都是非常相似的车型。涉案男子的外貌描述也各不相同，使得难以确定哪些人应对哪些行为负责。当局下令对所有现有证据进行全面的法医审查，但可供参考的证据比最初想象的还要少。人们曾希望用于捆绑洛林和温迪的绳子能揭示肇事者的DNA痕迹，但测试结果呈阴性。部分证据已在2010年被处理掉，而其他物品则
been lost altogether. Amongst the missing items was the silver men's signant ring that was found at the crime scene. Wayne Boogie Hilton was known to wear a similar ring. Given the ring had been misplaced, images of it couldn't be circulated to facilitate the identification of its owner. In the 1970s, the Laurie family had owned a pale green EH Holden with a white roof. The shell of this vehicle was tracked down and examined. Traces of blood were detected inside, but too much time had passed for it to be of any use. There was one notable discovery. There were no interior handles or window winders on the back doors. The inquest commenced into Wumba in April 2013. For the first time, the seven primary suspects were publicly named. They included Wayne Boogie
完全丢失了。丢失的物品中包括在犯罪现场发现的一枚男士银质图章戒指。韦恩·“布吉”·希尔顿以佩戴类似的戒指而闻名。由于戒指被弄丢了，无法分发照片来协助确认其所有者。在20世纪70年代，洛里家族拥有一辆带有白色车顶的浅绿色EH霍顿车。这辆车的残骸被找到并进行了检查。车内检测到了血迹，但时间过去太久，已无济于事。有一个值得注意的发现。后门没有内部把手或车窗摇柄。调查于2013年4月在图文巴开始。七名主要嫌疑人首次被公开点名。他们包括韦恩·“布吉”·希尔顿、
Hilton, Donald Laurie, Alan Shorty Laurie, Alan Ungey Laurie, Desmond Hilton, Jimmy O'Neill, and Larry Charles. Kingsley Hunt, the gang's designated driver, was noted as a person of interest, but not nominated as a primary suspect. Over several days, evidence was heard from the various witnesses who claimed to have seen Lorraine and Wendy with a group of men on the day they went missing. Other individuals who provided testimony ranged from the reliable to the questionable, with one member of the Laurie family claiming to have witnessed the murders himself when he was 10 years old. Many witnesses connected to the persons of interest gave vague, non-committed answers. Some backtracked from damning claims they'd made in the past,
唐纳德·洛里、艾伦·“矮子”·洛里、艾伦·“昂格”·洛里、德斯蒙德·希尔顿、吉米·奥尼尔和拉里·查尔斯。该团伙的指定司机金斯利·亨特被列为相关人员，但未被提名为主要嫌疑人。在几天的时间里，法庭听取了多名证人的证词，他们声称在失踪当天看到洛林和温迪与一群男子在一起。其他提供证词的人员从可靠到可疑不等，其中一名洛里家族成员声称他在10岁时亲眼目睹了谋杀过程。许多与相关人员有联系的证人给出了模糊、不置可否的回答。有些人推翻了他们过去做出的定罪陈述，
while several retracted their statements pertaining to alleged confessions. Those implicated flat out denied any involvement in the crime. Yet, there was an air of anticipation when one particular person finally took the stand. 1984 marked a decade after Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans were killed. Towards the middle of that year, Kim Sandercock had been having a tough time at home. She headed to Toowoomba's Crown Hotel for a breather. Kim sat nursing a drink when a woman whom she'd never met approached her table. The stranger took a seat and introduced herself as Ellen.
而几个人撤回了关于所谓供词的陈述。那些被牵连的人断然否认参与了犯罪。然而，当某个人最终走上证人席时，空气中弥漫着一种期待。1984年是洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯被杀后的第十年。那年中旬，金·桑德科克在家中过得很艰难。她前往图文巴的皇冠酒店透透气。金坐着喝饮料时，一个她从未见过的女人走近了她的桌子。那个陌生人坐下来，介绍自己叫艾伦。
The two women engaged in small talk for a while before Ellen, who was clearly intoxicated, asked, Have you ever had to carry around a secret that you couldn't tell anybody? It was clear to Kim that Ellen had something she wanted to get off her chest, so she let her talk. But Kim wasn't prepared for what came next. Ellen revealed that she'd been present when Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans were murdered, and she was sick of covering up for those responsible. Ellen claimed that she'd been driving around in a 1963 Holden with two men when they decided to pick up the two nurses in the hopes of getting sex. But the nurses refused the men's advances
两个女人闲聊了一会儿，然后显然喝醉了的艾伦问：“你有没有不得不背负一个不能告诉任何人的秘密？”金很清楚艾伦有什么心事想倾诉，所以她让她说下去。但金没有准备好迎接接下来的内容。艾伦透露，她在洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯被谋杀时在场，她厌倦了为肇事者掩盖罪行。艾伦声称，她当时和两个男人坐在一辆1963年的霍顿车里，他们决定接上那两名护士，希望能发生性关系。但护士们拒绝了男人们的求欢，
and were labelled as, quote, prick teasers. The men wanted to teach the nurses a lesson. The plan was to take them to an isolated area and rape them. But during the drive, things went haywire. The nurses became terrified and tried to escape. One of them had been sitting in the front seat, and the driver began hitting her over the head and pulling her hair. The other man, who was sitting in the back seat, grabbed a bar of some kind. He reached over and bashed the woman across the head. She flung forward, blood flying everywhere, and it was obvious that she was dead. The other nurse was hysterical. She began screaming. The men panicked and decided they'd have to kill her, too.
并被贴上了“挑逗者”的标签。男人们想给护士们一个教训。计划是把她们带到一个偏僻的地方强奸她们。但在开车过程中，事情失控了。护士们变得惊恐万分，试图逃跑。其中一人坐在前座，司机开始猛击她的头部并拉扯她的头发。坐在后座的另一个男人抓起某种棍棒。他伸过身去，猛击那个女人的头部。她向前扑倒，鲜血四溅，很明显她已经死了。另一个护士歇斯底里。她开始尖叫。男人们惊慌失措，决定也必须杀了她。
They pulled up to a remote side in Murphy's Creek and dumped the first body. The remaining nurse saw this as her chance to escape. She got out and ran, but the men chased her down. They launched a frenzied attack, bashing her multiple times in the head until she was no longer moving. They then dragged her body alongside her friend. When Ellen finally stopped talking about the murders, Kim was shaking as she got up to leave. Ellen grabbed her firmly by the shoulder and warned, if you ever tell anyone what I just told you, you'll end up the same way as the nurses. Kim was terrified. She kept this information to herself for five years before finally going to
他们把车开到墨菲溪的一个偏僻地点，抛下了第一具尸体。剩下的护士认为这是她逃跑的机会。她跑了出去，但男人们追上了她。他们发动了疯狂的袭击，多次猛击她的头部，直到她不再动弹。然后他们把她的尸体拖到她朋友身边。当艾伦终于停止谈论谋杀案时，金起身离开时浑身发抖。艾伦紧紧抓住她的肩膀警告说：“如果你敢把刚才告诉你的事告诉任何人，你的下场会和那些护士一样。”金吓坏了。她把这些信息藏在心里五年，直到最终去
the police. By then, she couldn't remember much about Ellen herself, but could remember every detail about the story Ellen had told her, including the names of the men involved. Shorty Laurie and one of the Hilton boys. By the time Kim Sandercock appeared at the inquest in 2013, she was in a wheelchair and hooked up to a morphine drip as the result of a spinal injury. She relied heavily on strong pain medication, which severely hindered her memory. Consequently, Kim claimed she had absolutely no recollection of Ellen and the conversation they shared in 1984. The court wasn't buying it. They believed it was more likely that the encounter with Ellen was a fabrication to cover for the fact that Kim knew more than she was willing
找了警察。到那时，她记不清艾伦本人了，但能记住艾伦告诉她的故事的每一个细节，包括涉案男子的名字。“矮子”·洛里和希尔顿家的一个男孩。当金·桑德科克在2013年的调查中出庭时，她因脊柱受伤坐在轮椅上，并挂着吗啡点滴。她严重依赖强效止痛药，这严重损害了她的记忆力。因此，金声称她对艾伦以及她们在1984年的谈话完全没有记忆。法庭并不买账。他们认为，这更有可能是一个编造的故事，用来掩盖金知道的比她愿意承认的更多的事实。
to admit. After all, what were the chances that an individual would approach a complete stranger in a pub to confess to witnessing a murder? Furthermore, the level of detail she'd managed to retain in her statement was outstanding. A more plausible explanation was that Kim herself had witnessed the crime and wanted to unburden herself without fear of retaliation or punishment. This fit with the witness statement from Brian and Velma, who claimed to have seen a third woman in the car with Lorraine and Wendy. Alternatively, someone close to Kim might have been involved and had told her the story enough times for her to retain such an accurate level of detail. These possibilities were put forward to Kim's Sandercock in court.
毕竟，一个人在酒吧里向完全陌生的人承认目睹谋杀案的可能性有多大？此外，她在陈述中保留的细节水平非常惊人。一个更合理的解释是，金本人目睹了犯罪过程，并希望在不担心报复或惩罚的情况下卸下心头重担。这与布莱恩和维尔玛的证词相符，他们声称看到车里有第三个女人和洛林、温迪在一起。或者，金身边的人可能参与其中，并多次告诉她这个故事，以至于她能保留如此准确的细节。这些可能性在法庭上被提给了金·桑德科克。
She flat out denied being present when Lorraine and Wendy were attacked, or having any first-hand knowledge of what happened. The coroner made it clear that Kim could be given immunity if she was willing to share what she knew. Kim replied, I can't remember. I just can't. The coroner presented his findings in June 2013. He concluded that the witness statement that held the most veracity was the one given by Kim Sandercock. The details she provided aligned with the crime scene. Lorraine had been killed by a single blow to the head before the perpetrators carried out a rage-fuelled frenzy on Wendy as she tried to escape. The coroner concluded that Kim
她断然否认在洛林和温迪遇袭时在场，也否认对发生的事情有任何第一手了解。验尸官明确表示，如果金愿意分享她所知道的情况，可以给予她豁免权。金回答说：“我不记得了。我真的不记得了。”验尸官在2013年6月提交了他的调查结果。他得出结论，可信度最高的证词是金·桑德科克提供的。她提供的细节与犯罪现场相符。洛林在被袭击者对试图逃跑的温迪进行疯狂发泄之前，被一击击中头部身亡。验尸官得出结论，金
had to likely either be present when the crimes were committed or had a close connection to someone who was. The coroner viewed the alleged confession that Wayne Hilton had made to his former colleague as valid. As for the number of witnesses who ignored Lorraine and Wendy's screams for help, he put this down to the bystander's effect. This socio-psychological phenomenon dictates that the more witnesses there are to an event, the less likely any one of them will offer help. The coroner remarked, with the failure of any of those people to even attempt to intervene went the girl's last chance of survival. He went on,
很可能要么在犯罪发生时在场，要么与在场的人有密切联系。验尸官认为韦恩·希尔顿对他前同事所做的所谓供词是有效的。至于那些无视洛林和温迪求救尖叫的证人，他将其归因于“旁观者效应”。这种社会心理学现象表明，目击者越多，其中任何一个人提供帮助的可能性就越小。验尸官评论道：“随着这些人甚至没有尝试干预，女孩们生存的最后机会也随之消失了。”他继续说道，
the lives of these two fine young women and the happiness of their families were shattered by an unprovoked violent vicious attack mounted to satiate the perverse sexual dysfunction of a despicable gang of thugs. Their family's suffering was made worse still by a long period of not knowing. Speaking about the seven persons of interest, the coroner stated that they'd gotten away with committing their habitual sexual assaults in the 70s because of the victim-blaming mentality of the time and the fact that survivors were too scared to come forward. He concluded, it is more likely than not Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans tragically stumbled into this putrid pool of miscreants and were killed by them. Undoubtedly, they were abducted and killed by more
“这两位优秀年轻女性的生命和她们家庭的幸福，被一群卑鄙的暴徒为了满足其变态的性功能障碍而发动的无端、暴力、恶毒的袭击所摧毁。”她们家庭的痛苦因长期的未知而变得更加严重。在谈到七名相关人员时，验尸官指出，他们在70年代之所以能逃脱习惯性的性侵犯，是因为当时受害者有罪论的心态，以及幸存者太害怕而不敢站出来的事实。他总结道：“洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯很可能不幸误入了这群腐烂的恶棍之中，并被他们杀害。毫无疑问，她们是被不止一个人绑架并杀害的，但肇事者的身份现在无法以足够的确定性确定，只有一个例外，即韦恩·希尔顿。”
than one person, but the identity of those responsible cannot now be established with sufficient certainty, with one exception, namely, Wayne Hilton. I am satisfied the evidence implicating him in the death of the two women reaches the required standard for a coroner's finding to that effect. By the time he was implicated in the double homicide, Wayne Hilton had been dead for 27 years. He was killed in a car accident in 1986. As such, he would not face any justice for his involvement. As for his associates, the coroner conceded that there was insufficient evidence to have any of them stand trial. With that, the inquest was closed. Three other members of the Hilton-Lorraine gang were deceased by the time the 2013
“我确信，将他牵连进这两名女性死亡的证据达到了验尸官做出相应结论所需的标准。”到他被牵连进这起双重谋杀案时，韦恩·希尔顿已经去世27年了。他于1986年死于一场车祸。因此，他不会因其参与而面临任何正义的审判。至于他的同伙，验尸官承认没有足够的证据让他们中的任何一人接受审判。至此，调查结束。到2013年调查进行时，希尔顿-洛里团伙的其他三名成员已经去世。一场车祸夺去了艾伦·“矮子”·洛里的生命。拉里·查尔斯于1993年自杀。唐纳德·洛里于1994年因长期疾病去世。
inquest was underway. A car accident had claimed Alan Shorty Lorraine's life in 2001. Larry Charles took his own life in 1993. Donald Lorraine had died in 1994 from a long-standing illness. According to one friend, Donald had made a deathbed confession, saying, "'We killed the nurses. I was there. I didn't do it.'" The friend claimed to have reported this to police, who took no significant action. Those who were still alive were Desmond Hilton, Jimmy O'Neill and Alan Ungey-Larry, all of whom were aged in their early 60s. When appearing at the inquest, all were notably cagey. Desmond, who had been warned he could be charged with being an accessory after the fact for cleaning
据一位朋友说，唐纳德在临终前曾忏悔说：“是我们杀了那些护士。我在场。但我没动手。”这位朋友声称已向警方报告了此事，但警方没有采取任何重大行动。仍然在世的是德斯蒙德·希尔顿、吉米·奥尼尔和艾伦·“昂格”·洛里，他们都已60出头。在调查中出庭时，所有人都表现得非常谨慎。德斯蒙德曾被警告，如果他在其他人据称谈论“把两个女孩藏起来”后清理了车子，他可能会被指控为从犯，但他声称对曾向警方做出此类陈述毫无记忆。在证人席上，这三名男子中的每一位都试图通过否认他们曾经是朋友或在70年代在一起消磨时间来与其他人保持距离。
the car after the others allegedly spoke of giving two girls a hiding, claimed he had no memory of ever making such a statement to the police. On the stand, each of the three men attempted to distance themselves from the others by denying they were ever friends or spent time together back in the 70s. Back in 1976, Officer Ian Hamilton of the Toowoomba police had met with detectives working the Wilson Evans case to divulge everything he knew about the Green Holden and the Hilton and Lorraine men who were associated with it. It was only through the inquest that he learned no record was ever made of this meeting. Officer Hamilton told the Courier Mail, there is no doubt in my mind that if those leads were followed up, the case would have been solved
早在1976年，图文巴警方的伊恩·汉密尔顿警官曾与负责威尔逊-埃文斯案的侦探会面，披露了他所知道的关于绿色霍顿车以及与之相关的希尔顿和洛里男子的所有信息。直到调查时，他才知道这次会议从未留下任何记录。汉密尔顿警官告诉《信使邮报》：“我毫不怀疑，如果那些线索得到跟进，案件早就破了，而且会很快破案，因为嫌疑人会吓得要死，肯定会有人告密。”
and solved quickly, because the suspects would have been shitting themselves and someone would have squealed. Whether they would have got them all, I don't know, but someone would have been brought to justice. Although Lorraine and Wendy's loved ones were disappointed that no tangible justice had been served, they were grateful that someone had finally been held accountable and that those suspected of being involved had been publicly named and shamed. Outside court, Lorraine's cousin told reporters, I don't think they'll be able to walk down the street now and feel comfortable. I think naming them has probably been the best outcome that we could have here.
“他们是否能抓住所有人，我不知道，但肯定会有人被绳之以法。”尽管洛林和温迪的亲人对没有实现实质性的正义感到失望，但他们很感激终于有人被追究责任，并且那些被怀疑参与其中的人被公开点名和羞辱。在法庭外，洛林的表亲告诉记者：“我不认为他们现在还能走在街上感到自在。我认为点名他们可能是我们能得到的最好结果。”
Lorraine's brother Eric found peace with the fact that the community was now aware of the criminals walking among them. Quote, the mountain of fear that sat on my shoulders can sit on theirs now. Eric sought permission from the Toowoomba Regional Council to install a memorial plaque in a park garden in the name of his sister and Wendy Evans. After some back and forth, Eric's request was denied. Eric said of the decision, it was an excellent opportunity to make amends and acknowledge what happened, not only to the girls, but the community who have been held hostage for 40 years. Had it been installed, the plaque would have included the message,
洛林的兄弟埃里克对社区现在意识到他们中间潜伏着罪犯这一事实感到平静。引用他的话：“压在我肩上的恐惧之山现在可以压在他们身上了。”埃里克向图文巴地区议会寻求许可，以他姐姐和温迪·埃文斯的名义在公园花园安装一块纪念牌。经过一番反复，埃里克的请求被拒绝了。埃里克在谈到这个决定时说：“这是一个绝佳的机会来弥补过失并承认所发生的一切，不仅是对女孩们，也是对被劫持了40年的社区。”如果安装了，牌匾上会包含这样的信息：
fear and intimidation must never again silence a community. The so-called Gold Coast hitchhiker murderer who is believed to be responsible for the deaths of Michelle Riley, Gabrielle Janky, Robin Huyenville-Bartram, Anita Cunningham and Margaret Rosewarn has never been brought to justice. Investigators don't believe that the Hilton and Lurie gang were involved with these crimes. Hopes remain that advances in genealogical DNA testing could soon lead to the killer or killers being identified. A plaque in memory of Lorraine Wilson and Wendy Evans was installed on the grounds of St George Hospital in Sydney where the pair had worked as trainee nurses. For Lorraine's mother, Betty, it was ironic that her daughter had a particular
“恐惧和恐吓绝不能再次让社区沉默。”所谓的“黄金海岸搭车杀手”，被认为应对米歇尔·莱利、加布里埃尔·扬基、罗宾·休恩维尔-巴特拉姆、安妮塔·坎宁安和玛格丽特·罗斯沃恩的死亡负责，至今仍未被绳之以法。调查人员不认为希尔顿和洛里团伙与这些罪行有关。人们仍然希望基因DNA检测的进步能很快导致杀手或杀手们被识别出来。一块纪念洛林·威尔逊和温迪·埃文斯的牌匾被安装在悉尼圣乔治医院的场地上，这对搭档曾在那里担任实习护士。对于洛林的母亲贝蒂来说，具有讽刺意味的是，她的女儿对精神科护理有着特殊的
interest in psychiatric nursing. Prior to Betty's death, she remarked, It seems the kind of people Lorraine wanted to help most ended up killing her. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
兴趣。在贝蒂去世前，她曾评论道：“似乎洛林最想帮助的那类人最终杀害了她。”目前还没有关于本集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。